excellent
this is how i like to meet people hello
gq i'm tom segura
and these are my essentials
[Music]
listen i'm a professional traveler you
can think whatever you want of me
but i know how to travel
hats are a must look at this one it's
got my initials on it
ts it's got a bunch of gold chains it's
perfect
for letting people know you're the man
also hats are great for flights man you
might be like oh yeah wear hats because
you're bald no
i wear a hat so i can do this avoid eye
contact get some real sleep you know
i probably own i don't know maybe 150
hats they're everywhere
every room i go into there's a hat i get
yelled at a lot at home for it
headphones are key for travel for so
many reasons
first of all the drive to the airport i
don't want to talk
i put these on puts me in a good mood
when i walk through an airport
i like to pick music so it's like a
soundtrack
to that morning big fan of putting on
the sicario
score you know the movie sicario the
soundtrack of that film is terrifying
so when you walk through an airport and
you're listening to it you feel like
is about to go down and i find it
exciting i find it fun
i also wear headphones you know when i
get to the hotel you go to the gym with
them on
it's just it's key i'm a big fan of
buying
inexpensive headphones even though i
have a few nice ones because
i lose them misplace them damage them
whatever
i can't go on any trip without
headphones
i bring three pairs of shoes minimum on
every trip so you have your comfortable
shoes on that you're wearing
you can walk through the airport blah
blah blah then you have like your show
shoes that's what these would be why
because these are fresh man
you wear these on stage you look good
you feel good you feel good you play
good
you play good they pay good what's up
deon
shout out to prime time i also bring an
extra
pair of sneakers usually just for
exercise because you know you don't want
these up i'm not going to wear these to
the gym are you crazy
so clean no way always bring cool kicks
on the road
[Music]
i don't discriminate i'll buy any kind
of underwear boxer briefs are what i
prefer but i don't care about the brand
i just want a lot of options and here's
why you're going to land and you're
going to want to shower and after the
shower you want
clean underwear okay you're still on day
one you're now on your second pair of
underwear
oh i gotta work it out i gotta you know
shake off the jet lag
cool go to the gym another pair of
underwear wake up the next morning oh
no shot my pants last night third pair
underwear you need
more underwear than there are days if
you're going on a three-day trip
bring six seven pair underwear that's
how it has to be
i always pack too many underwear too
many socks i never regret it you should
do it too
a pouch with every cable listen
you just can never have too many cables
but the problem is you don't want them
loose you want them in one concentrated
area
so whenever anything comes up you have a
cable
for it you can start a vcr from 1986
what they
have in here you could bring me some
hard drive that they're making
in seoul right now that hasn't been
released that you can start it up with
something in this pouch
i've been on the road with people and
they're like i don't know how to get
this phone worked
they go through this pouch they try to
steal my cable
i will cut your hand off before you
leave with my cables
i love backpacks i buy them all the time
they're addictive you know i like having
like the different compartments and
pouches
this backpack is durable weatherproof i
can do
you know an overnight or two-day trip
with uh just
this and another small bag you know i
put my laptop in here i put reading
materials in here
everything essential that i need is in
this backpack it's made by tumi
who also happens to have the best
warranty
i mean anything goes wrong with the tumi
product you just take it in
or you ship it in and they either fix it
or they send you a brand new one i love
it i love you to me
send me some more
i'm really sensitive to light i always
like dark rooms you know to sleep in and
i'm like why haven't i tried this now i
have a collection of sleep masks and it
is a game
changer just make every room a blackout
room
you sleep deeper you sleep better since
i started using them i
have not stopped i used to tie t-shirts
around my face
when i slept like a friggin
bush league hostage and then i realized
oh
i can just look cool and sleep deep dude
it is
terrifyingly dark in here you want to
sleep deep get a sleep mask
i'm a comedian i'm always taking notes i
carry these
in my backpack in my pocket in my
jackets and if i ever have something i
want to jot down
easy reach for it i like these pilot
g2 i like them and i really like these
right here
the uh ener yeah the energel liquid gel
ink
it just kind of flows easily i think you
buy a pack for you know five bucks or
something
i just keep collecting pens i can never
have enough i write things down it's how
i retain it in my memory
get some pens
[Music]
i get a lot of bombers i just like the
way they look
i like the way they feel they're
stylistically cool
you know you throw a bomber on you're
good in any city you can go into a
restaurant
you can go to a show you can go on a
date i just brought a few
from the house i have uh countless
countless it's another thing i get a lot
for but honestly
i just feel like it is the perfect
jacket i mean jacket weather
is the best weather a bomber is the
perfect jacket
there's no need to go in any other
direction it's sporty
it can be elegant it's the way to go i
wear them at almost every show that i do
i have for the last three or four years
and there's no slowing down
thank you so much gq i'm tom segura
and these are my essentials